I hope you're not tired of grand theft
auto online because rockstar has just
launched another new game type drop zone
is all about leaping from a helicopter
parachuting to a control point and
holding down the fort drop zone supports
up to four teams of 16 players each so
expect plenty of competition with this
one your goal is to hold down the zone
for a total of two minutes but each map
requires totally different tactics you
can play the new game type at pill box
hill Richmond college Elysian Island
mayor Park and the Sisyphus theater the
update has also made some changes to
Benny's original motor works now you can
upgrade the care insulting into the
Karen sultan RS and the bravado banshee
into the verve otto banshee 900 are both
of these are high performance wide-body
race cars that rockstar says are good
enough to compete with the zentorno or
t20 drop zone is only available on ps4
xbox one and pc and it won't be the last
update rockstar has already teased new
content for the games Valentine's Day
update for more information on that plus
all the Grand Theft Auto news you need
stay tuned to gamespot